Susan page USA TODAY's Washington bureau
chief joins us now Susan good morning
good morning as Paula mentioned
President Trump was was not mentioned by
name really in the end the service but
but you view it as as kind of a
collective rebuke I think that's right
his name was never spoken but the
message was pretty clear those it was a
saw the Washington establishment and
including big figure the congressional
leadership now three presidents a whole
series of people have played big roles
in American government we're standing up
and saying we want a different kind of
of politics and I think that was part of
Senator McCain's plan by asking the two
men who defeated him in his aspirations
for the White House to speak I mean that
is the maybe the ultimate expression of
bipartisanship and Susan we know the
president was not there he was golfing
he did tweet later make America great
again do you think he received the
message that you're talking about right
now and did he hear it I think that
tweet that he posted last night was
pretty clearly a response to Meghan
McCain and so yes I think we saw a sort
of debate in absentia a debate over a
distance about the state of America the
state of American democracy how Congress
works I think this was a big memorial
service it was about more than Senator
McCain's life alone it was about his
vision for how American democracy ought
to work in the way it does not seem to
be working today Susan
tomorrow the hearings began for Brett
Kavanaugh what do you make of the 100
pages of documents that are being
withheld so unprecedented an
announcement made by the White House
Friday night that all these documents
from his time as staff secretary to
George W Bush will not be released the
first formal assertion of this executive
power for a Supreme Court nominee but
I've got to say Democrats are having
trouble getting traction against Brett
Kavanaugh Republicans are very
optimistic that he is going to be
confirmed with the support of all the
Republicans and probably a couple
Democratic votes as well two months
until the midterms Susan how is the
president at play
amongst voters now should he be on the
campaign trail will that be helpful for
Republicans well try to keep him away
because I think he likes to campaign so
I think he will be out there but you
know we have a new USA Today subject
poll that we ask people do you want to
elect a congress that stands up to
President Trump or one that cooperates
with President Trump and by 58% to 34%
Americans told them told us they want a
Congress elected that will stand up to
the president not cooperate with them
Susan page thank you thank you